this fish is worth more than a ferrari
not just because of its good looks
they're sturgeon
and inside each one is a small fortune
in caviar
what's even more surprising is that
they're not russian these fish
are chinese
[Applause]
foreign
island lake 220 miles southwest of
shanghai
and it's home to kaluga queen china's
first homegrown caviar company
it was set up by officials who worked in
the chinese ministry of agriculture in
2003.
good timing it was just as countries
announced bans on fishing wild sturgeon
the traditional method of production in
the caspian sea
this isn't just a story about the
unexpected origins of some
very expensive fish this is about
china's global reach and ambition
15 years ago china didn't have a caviar
industry now it's the world's biggest
producer
and these farms alone account for nearly
a third of total production
is what happens when chinese business
with the approval of the state
sets out to conquer the world and it
does it without the world even really
noticing
like other types of farming caviar
involves wrangling
these are new additions to the lake once
the fingerlings
technical term for baby fish have grown
up enough they live here for three or
four years
then they're taken on to land and this
is where you can see the true scale of
the operation
when they're eight years old 15 years
for the more expensive species
they have enough eggs and they end up
here
the fish are cut open and their eggs
extracted before the fish is killed
and used for food the eggs are cleaned
inspected
salted and then they become caviar ready
to be flown to the 25 countries kaluga
queen supplies
the whole process from first cut to
caviar in a tin takes 15 minutes
first one is the siberian sturgeon
and this is the result caviar that's
ended up on the tables of both the queen
and
kim jong-un according to the company's
head of international sales
sky news did its journalistic duty and
sampled the goods
in the beginning they they are surprised
because caviar china is
they never heard about caviar from china
we have many doubts about the quality
about the
safety and although kovid has meant
international sales have dropped 20
this year galuga has focused on the 1.4
billion
strong chinese market to make up the
shortfall we did a lot of promotion to
introduce
the cavity culture to the chinese people
now more and more people start to
consume camera and light carrier to be
carrier friends it seems to be working
kaliga queen is planning to go public
next year the valuation of around 600
million pounds
plotting a course through chinese waters
to global domination tom cheshire sky
news
chen dao lake east china